like there's just been decline in the
population like this just not enough as
there used to be guess it would be
chemicals like fertilizer environmental
effects whether it's global warming or
pesticides like building homes on there
in their environment GMOs and so the gun
it's affecting bees there's stuff like
anise oil cities and people I don't know
much a lot of people don't realize that
without the honeybees they're
pollinating for our food supply we would
not last as a civilization for more than
five years this is a high that I we
rescued we relocated and we maintained
for a resident here who benefits from
the honey having a garden pollinated and
then we just come through and keep the
bees happy and healthy so today was a
what I would call regular hive
maintenance going by a hive that I
maintain for a resident checking over so
you kind of have the hives looking how
the health is see if we need to add any
boxes make sure that the Queen's laying
so this is a small part of what I do the
majority of my work is in the field
doing removals so I'm doing swarm and
hive removals all day long all over the
county these are extremely important you
rely on them more than we realize for
all of our food for pollination and for
honey and liver our diet we have a
growing population and everyone's
relying on this food that is really a
surplus of food that is there because we
like to spread the beekeeping knowledge
get more people into it more people are
into it the more their friends get into
it and questions and the awareness
spreads and in turn you get more
pollinators in more areas that we're
seeing less season
I study honeybee health as well as
native species health I focus on
environmental stressors that honeybees
can be exposed to the most important
aspect of honeybees for humans is that
they pollinate and that's extremely
important because they pollinate wild
plants which and that guarantees the
reproduction of these plants increasing
the biodiversity in the environment and
therefore the biodiversity of the
animals presence in the environment the
also pollination is also essential for
the production of fruits and vegetables
concerning honeybee health usually we
are exposed to many environmental
stressors which are for example diseases
nutritional deficits habitat loss
pesticides for example and all of these
factors likely contribute to the
phenomenon of or the halt of the
honeybee decline it's multiple reasons
what is housing the honeybee collapse
number one thread is chemicals number
two is commercial beekeeping practices
which is a necessary evil number three
is mono crops what is causing colony
collapse disorder is that combination
the reality of it is poisons they're
selling in your average hardware store
it's killing the bees and the old days
you would spray something on the outside
that would kill any bugs that come near
the leaf people want to just pour a
bottle of something on something and not
have to do it for a year they sell it
like gallons at Home Depot it's sucked
up by the plant every leaf every insect
that either feeds up nectar pollen or
leave ends up dying
the biggest issue facing the beans right
now is called the CCD or colony collapse
disorder this is an issue where beehives
are missing the Queen is there but the
worker bees don't come back to the hive
it doesn't match any of the known
diseases and pests that have that
normally killed our bee hives like
american-style brood and gorilla mites
and all these other disruptors it's
unknown exactly what's causing this and
that's what's causing most fear and
panic with people trying to figure this
out and with this colony collapse
disorder and the issue that we're facing
losing these it's an issue that a lot of
people think it's just like another bug
going extinct it's not such a big deal
we don't have the means to support our
population with enough food without
these pollinators they they triple our
harvests when they pollinate and without
their pollinating then we get the normal
harvest and it's not nearly enough for
our growing population to survive so
honeybees are detrimental to human
civilization survival when the farmers
their mate you know producing less fruit
then we're paying more to get that fruit
and that's the first effective entity
before food shortages the prices are
going to rise to pretty extreme Heights
colony numbers have dropped so there's
not as many bees available for
pollination it's extremely hard on the
beekeeping community the beekeepers to
come out to work the hives there'd be no
bees in a hive whatsoever I think the
biggest culprit is called a varroa mite
it's a related to fleas it's a parasite
you can have a virus associated with the
mite it could get injected into the beam
and later on a virus takes off into the
colony and it can kill it the mites
themselves can overpopulate they can get
such a large population in a short
period of time the mess the bees don't
survive an eight-bit collapse typically
the varroa mite which is a cause of a
disease of the honeybee is the major
problem for economies we find it more
difficult to survive in the environment
in recent years because of the increased
impact of humans on the unemployment
beekeeping is very important for
maintaining the current levels of bee
population in fact beekeepers help
reproduce honeybee colonies and when
there is a decline when they have a loss
of honeybees they can produce other bee
colonies from one so live removals are a
better option over an extermination for
a bee hive for a couple of reasons
you're helping the in the long run of
the ecosystem keeping the pollinators
healthy population of native honeybees
and you're also just putting out less of
the insecticide and poisons into the
ground because it's a-you don't exactly
know who all is going to be end up
getting contaminated by that so what the
day-to-day people who are involved in
beekeeping themselves can do to help
bees is making an effort to shop for
fruits and vegetables that are non-gmo
and organic planting wildflowers not
using products like roundup being
informed about what insecticides are
dangerous and which ones are less using
more natural insecticides for their own
gardens and yard and informing their
neighbors of what types of insecticides
are harming the end
the bees and stuff if you know of a
neighbor that's right
I'll make sure that whatever success
besides you might be using in your own
home are not harmful to bees well I
think it's always positive to use less
toxic chemicals compost you know costing
and using like fresh fertilizers they
choose not to buy produce and things
like that that are grown using
pesticides
[Music]